[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes les fondateurs de l'espace
combien d'entre vous, enfants,
rêvaient d'être astronaute j'étais l'un
de ces enfants
j'ai toujours été fasciné par l'espace
de mon point de vue l'espace contient les
clés de tant de questions fondamentales
comme d'où nous venons  d'où et où nous
allons
nous êtres humains flottant dans l'
immensité de l'univers
et ce minuscule grain de poussière que nous appelons la
terre
je suis curieux de connaître notre avenir sur terre
et dans l'espace
quand je regarde le ciel j'aimerais
appuyer sur un bouton  sur ma montre comme un
super
-héros et déployer un sac à dos avec une ceinture de fusée
et de petits propulseurs
, puis un puissant jet pack de vol
me mettrait dans
le ciel en passant à travers les nuages comme si da
s un vaisseau spatial se dirigeant vers les étoiles ouais
c'était mon rêve comme  un enfant que
je connais maintenant en tant qu'adulte ce n'est pas le
rêve le plus crédible au monde
mais une chose que je crois toujours fermement
est que j'aimerais aller dans l'espace
parce que l'espace a l'air incroyable
prenons l'exemple de l'apesanteur  ness
j'ai effectué deux vols en apesanteur
et je peux vous dire que je me souviendrai toujours
de
mon premier vol parabolique en
apesanteur
voler sans ressentir de poids sans
aucun bruit sur votre corps offre une sensation
de liberté totale
imaginez ouvrir votre main
et lâcher une petite balle  et voir
juste la gorge immobile est
absolument incroyable
si quelqu'un vous donne une petite poussée avec un
effet de rotation,
vous commencez à vous retourner et rien ne peut
vous arrêter
sauf la fin du droit public
mais vous avez toujours ce nouveau super pouvoir
pour voler plus facilement qu'un oiseau qui  c'est magique
et voir toutes les personnes se déplacer autour de vous
sans effort sans aucun référentiel pour le
temps et l'espace
c'est comme dans un rêve éveillé
voudriez-vous venir avec moi
et essayer
ouais je peux dire ces oui
maintenant il ne s'agit pas seulement de ce que tu ressens
c'est aussi ce que vous voyez
la vue de la terre depuis l'espace est
magnifique au-delà de l'
imagination
grâce aux astronautes travaillant dans la
station spatiale internationale dont
nous avons profité  tant de belles
photos
de la terre depuis nos lits pour
moi c'est tellement inspirant que cela devrait être pour
nous tous et
si nous pouvions monter là-haut
ensemble et voir une belle planète
de nos propres yeux
wow nous resterons
bouche bée d'admiration
je me souviens avoir eu cette sensation que
le temps s'arrête
quand je regarde en ligne et que je vois les
astronautes
marcher dans l'espace flottant dans l'espace
et c'est tellement impressionnant de les voir en
orbite autour de notre belle planète
je ne peux même pas imaginer le niveau de
contemplation
le sentiment de plénitude que nous aurions  atteindre
si nous pouvions expérimenter cela avec
nos cinq
sens, cela créerait à coup sûr une nouvelle
connexion
entre la terre et la terre ou la terre
notre belle planète
en plus de cette nouvelle connexion
en nous regardant a également accru
notre prise de conscience de notre fragilité
carl sagan était  appelant notre planète
ou des points bleu pâle tout en donnant
une vision du futur humain dans l'espace
tout en explorant le magnifique mystère
de l'univers en
regardant en arrière  la terre a révélé
qu'il existe de nombreuses menaces auxquelles la terre est
confrontée
jour après jour typhons
incendies tornades tsunamis
et parce que certains d'entre nous ont osé explorer
de
plus haut pourquoi d'autres tels que des
ingénieurs scientifiques et des chercheurs ont
multiplié leurs efforts pour développer de nouvelles
technologies
afin de mieux comprendre l'évolution de
notre terre,
nous les êtres humains, nous devenons plus intelligents,
nous avons élargi nos connaissances
de l'extérieur, nous avons pu
provoquer
une amélioration de l'intérieur
, un tel voyage peut inspirer la prochaine
génération
afin qu'elle puisse être excitée et curieuse
de l'espace
et de la terre, alors  ils peuvent jouer un rôle
dans la résolution de nos problèmes en créant de
nouvelles solutions et en développant de nouvelles
technologies
et en construisant nos connaissances collectives
et peut-être qu'un jour ils deviendront
eux-mêmes des explorateurs de l'
espace parce que l'espace est pour tout
le monde comme la vie sur terre concerne
tout le monde
devenir astronaute ne l'est pas  besoin de
rester un rêve
pour certaines personnes ça devient
alors osez rêver
je suis un roc  ingénieur ket et je peux vous dire que
je vois une grande diversité de projets
chaque année plusieurs nations
ont leurs fusées um leurs modules
leurs engins spatiaux
satellites prods sondes
rovers atterrisseur d'orbiteur toutes sortes d'
expériences
ces pays développent leurs compétences
chaque jour même une école peut envoyer un
cubesat
dans l'espace et ça se passe aujourd'hui
et vous l'utilisez tous les jours que
vous le sachiez ou non
nous en faisons tous partie c'est pourquoi je
veux explorer
et si j'avais la chance de choisir d'aller
sur mars
pourquoi mars
mars est notre ancienne terre
comme la sœur aînée de notre planète,
mars est un miroir de nous sur terre il y a
trois milliards d'années, mars et des années
étaient très similaires, mars
ajoute une atmosphère et des océans à cette
époque
et aujourd'hui, nous recherchons une trace
de cette couverture invisible par les océans que
nous regardons  tout signe
de ce début de vie passé,
nous avons des orbiteurs et des rovers qui travaillent dessus
pour trouver n'importe quelle cellule toute trace
de cette vie passée sur Mars
pouvez-vous imaginer ce qui va se passer
un jour
quand nous découvrirons la première preuve de
vie sur mars
cela changera le cours de l'histoire
notre histoire en tant qu'être humain sur terre
pour toujours pourquoi c'est si important
parce que nous devons comprendre comment et
pourquoi
les océans et les atmosphères ont
disparu il y a trois milliards d'années
vivant  dans un désert froid alors que d'une manière ou d'une autre
la terre a encore une atmosphère
et que la majeure partie de la surface est couverte par les
océans,
cela permettrait de créer une base de données
et des modèles dédiés
pour prédire cette évolution sur terre,
il n'y aura pas seulement une sorte de
simulations hypothétiques
avec ça  peuvent avoir un rapport avec la réalité,
ils refléteraient les étapes
de la vie sur le ren ma sur la planète rouge
et comment la vie a disparu
et cela nous dirait comment empêcher que
cela ne se produise
sur terre
cette connaissance de l'histoire martienne
sensibiliserait certainement avec
des faits des
données et des faits tangibles
cela nous fera comprendre où nous en
sommes
dans l'évolution de l'évolution de la
terre
ce qui va arriver à  demain
pour prévoir cette évolution et prendre des
mesures pour lutter contre les menaces
ralentir leurs causes et atténuer
leurs effets
et être conscient que notre temps sur terre
n'est pas forcément illimité si nous
ne
prenons pas bien soin d'elle
prenons l'exemple du changement climatique
imaginez à quel point ce serait utile si nous
pouvions mettre sur la table des faits des arguments des
mesures d'atténuation proposées des solutions concrètes proposées
pour empêcher que des catastrophes ne se produisent
sur la terre,
par exemple pour empêcher la fonte accélérée des
glaces
pour protéger nos forêts qui fournissent ce
qui est si important pour nous  pour
nous fournir notre oxygène
pour protéger nos habitats et nos familles
de la description du climat qui
nous rend si faibles
dans notre propre environnement
une connaissance approfondie du changement climatique sur
mars
nous permettrait de prédire cette
évolution
pour contrer ces effets
pour préserver la vie et notre être humain  espaces
cet effort, nous avons également le pouvoir d'
unir tant de personnes
ensemble de manière pacifique
de tous  pays
en abordant les problèmes fondamentaux sur
terre
et en nous donnant à tous quelque chose d'
optimiste à poursuivre,
c'est pourquoi je veux explorer et je
veux aller sur mars
non pas pour quitter la terre mais pour
apprendre à vivre ici et ensuite le
donner en héritage  à mes enfants
et à notre prochaine génération
offrant le passé au futur
fermez les yeux vous êtes au milieu de l'
espace
pas de gravité rien qui ne vous contraigne
en aucune façon liberté totale
dans un sens un petit point rouge
dans l'autre un petit point bleu
l'un est de comprendre l'autre
est d'être sauvé peu importe ce que vous choisissez d'
aller
l'autre doit être dans votre esprit et votre
cœur bon voyage merci
[Musique]
vous